moi j'ai rien casser si vous avez déjà
sauvé des vies parler vite vos accès au
fameux ouest la vie d'un plongeur
j'étais en plongée oui non oui à 30
mètres gérer le coran il fait la
vaisselle à gaza vers m'étais coupé et
nous était donc quatre mètres sous l'eau
évidemment j'ai vu le plongeur qui
allait pas bien et en fait il avait il
avait pu d'air donc je vais remonter
avec mon en bourse après celle en bouche
des remontées à la surface france pas
hélas il ya évidemment les briques
europe
castany et m'a pas reconnu à l'époque
j'étais pas à la télé vraiment commencé
rester ya longtemps ouest ayant depuis
sauf plus de rien il fait que des
régimes ben haim est ce que vous avez
déjà sauvé une vie valérie berger pas
sauver une vie mais j'ai fait arrêter
une bagarre entre deux hommes n'ont vu
mike harris
elle est allée les ports c'est un petit
bordel est parfait mais pas mieux encore
je gardais bernard naudy figurez-vous
que j'avais avec quoi six ans même pas
haut et en fait c'était de deux hommes y
en a un qui avait fait une queue de
poisson à l'autre bref peu importe donc
ils sont sortis dans sont venus en masse
ils ont commencé vraiment il y avait à
se bagarrer avait il y avait du sang moi
je crois me promenais avec ma maman sur
le sur le trottoir et on a vu cette
chose personne n'osait était tétanisé à
l'époque avait pas encore les téléphones
portables et donc moi petit bout de chou
j'y vois à l'époque et pas été vains
voilà et moi petit bout'chou de 5 6 ans
je me suis mise à hurler à l'époque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le samu cette émission car il sait
toujours pas si ça vient c'est pour
annoncer une barque à parce qu'on est
tous amis on dirait qu'on travaille chez
darty on dirait qu'on va avoir des
appels un service est pour le moment oui
c'est pour le mini hachoir
je vous vois ça je passe la tendance va
maintenant on est tous en poussent comme
des rois
alors il faut citer d'autres marques un
bien sûr ya l'art qui il ya bien sûr des
programmes scolaires crise le regard
perdu confiance sur leur tâche est pas
des déchets diminue à choix les femmes
qui est logique d'aller vers une pierre
je ne sais pas quoi deux pompiers et
pompiers merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que tu sors et
intervenez dans une dans une bagarre je
ne vais comme ça mais et jamais je
pensais que sont reprises sampler donc
non moi je resigne brouille comédien
david suzat havrais dans l'avion huawei
et puis moi je dis merci du monde
oui je savais que ça pouvait être grave
après donc fallait faire taire sans
bouger vite chez moi je partis dans ce
but là d'un jeu paper irait jusque dans
l'avion sans rigoler moi vous ou moi je
sais que quand je vais avec mes enfants
dans la blague je sais oublier que fait
mon brouille avec des gars à bon bah oui
mais enfoncer des ouf
il tape sur le ciel et vas-y et truc je
sais obligatoirement cd ça va partir en
cacahuète
non mais je le sais tu vois donc voilà
donc et qu'elle n'est pas le jeu vous
vous êtes pitch il va vous connaissez
voilà mais c'est vrai que moi mais c'est
vrai donc dans l'avion il ya souvent eu
des embrouilles dans l'avion je suis
d'accord qu'il ya sûrement des mecs
aussi qui font les beaux dans la bonne
entente on sait que quoi vous je te jure
que c'est vrai que je suis parti à
barcelone là ya trois semaines ouais je
monte dans l'avion c'est un wedding ses
pairs france je pouvais rien faire il
parlait pas français j'en équipage je
monte dans l'avion
il ya trois mecs qui passent quand je
suis assis il passe à côté de moi et me
disent de leurs mots petite fille je te
jure c'est vraiment là pour l'engager
alors sur ma vie c'était que mon pote
emmanuel il passa trois contents qu'est
ce que tu fais avant tu te lèves tu fais
un travail pas un m'appelez pas sommes
passés d'un avion labeling laraque
l'avion j'hésitais à me lever
mais si je fais un massacre ouais hein
c'est horrible à cet été puis je traduis
j'étais seul ils étaient trois et en
plus je reconnais que c'est pas très
courageuse yeux les abrutis un visa
beauty et tout ça je ne le connaissais
pas physiquement il est grand ouai ouai
mais jp d ouais
c'est ça la prochaine fois tu veux que
tu me le dise la musique est très zen
avait une chance de plus énervant c'est
à dire qu'est ce que je peux faire
parce qu'en vrai je sais pas me battre
je le reconnais tu es tu veux faire du
bateau mais d'un avion a frappé
quelqu'un ils sont 3 qu'est ce que tu
veux faire alors conservé la tête attend
que ça passe
cyril pardonnez moi mais je qu'est ce
que vous auriez fait très exactement ce
qu'il est dans un avion vous à lire dans
notre sens alors avec hanouna petit peu
déçue de laura je vais vous dire je vous
dis la vérité
ouais ça m'est jamais arrivé mais je
marche je monte un seul dans l'avion
passants qui braie mais je pense ça se
tape c'est sûr c'était sur dur c'est sûr
règle générale vous alors en fait j'ai
sauvé une vie vu j'ai déjà sauvé des
cheveux je sais j'ai pas vraiment sauver
des vies non j'ai sauvé des couples âgés
sauver d'exane avait détruit aussi n'ont
jamais pu sauver un homme jonathan durs
qui soient séparés pour éviter de va
essayer de rebond fait un peu la libido
des jeunes filles ou jeunes familles
sida ou de redonner le moral aux garçons
et c'est vrai que ces instruments
contribuer à ce qu'ils se remettent
ensemble après et qui repart du bon pied
hélas l'histoire est intéressante à
cannes j'avais une question quant à rich
en revanche alizé je voulais savoir si
la compagnie lui avait offert un cadeau
à la valeur de son événement jean paul
gratuit à vie en des cacahuètes un avion
alors mes notes gratuit ça a été
compliqué parce qu apparemment beaucoup
de médias l'ont contacté et ils ont
refusé de répondre et à la limite on m'a
fait comprendre tu as fait une très
mauvaise pub non nous en porter plainte
et légale onml eroglu torture
c'est vraiment en loups n'ont maintenant
mais c'est vrai problème d'affaires
ouais non car sauver une vie toi moi en
rapport à mon physique un solide j'ai
jamais eu l'occasion de sauver des vies
par contre on masse déjà sauvé la vie et
je remercie encore la personne qui m'a
sauvé l'asse je suis tombé dans un trou
non alors non je rigole du jeu j'en ai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
organisé une petite fête chez mes
parents et au moment de descendre pour
chercher du jus d'orange dans la came
part on m'avait pas prévenu qu'ils aient
des travaux est en fait y avait un trou
de 10 mètres non dans la cave et au
maillet en fait j'ai traversé je tombais
dans le trou je suis resté comme ça il
ya un copain qui a fait de mamoudou
gassama il est venu monsieur choper la
main et s'est offert une belle histoire
gilles verdez le retour hier alors
d'ailleurs sur une victoire on parie
coupant la pluie tarde à tomber c'est le
sénégal la commune tarder à tomber sur
le sénégal nous sommes au mois d'août
dernier à saint louis
oui tout d'un coup j'entends un crime je
reconnais la voix de fatou parce que je
la connais la boîte ça tout ça parce que
écrit avec ces flatteurs elle cria come
and cry bassa'a auquel un varan
aquafleur précipite jeux précédents elle
me dit un vendeur à chambé oui moi je
pense à godzilla mais non c'est un gecko
les légats les lézards translucide comme
ça arrive et ça lui fait hyper faire
donc je prends ma [ __ ]
là il y avait une tempête
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui je cours après le gco bon si
je crois appel gecko et je n'ai pas eu
dzeko mais il est parti j'ai pas vu ça
avant il est parti pour encore y derribo
co2 a jugé qu on avait aussi dit qu'il a
couru après les cours si j'ai couru
après vous non comment ce à quoi vous
avez déjà sauvé une vie vous met
blessures dans l'avion chez moi
bien que je frise j'ai plongé pour
sauver ma meilleure amie de la noyade je
vais ramener sur la rive et c'est une
plage qui teinte et là s'appelle
alassane et non mais t'as pas compris
les plus voir ta gueule pour moi tu m'as
sort et oui c'est la plage dans fiant
savoie aller à la pêche dans le fion oui
une plage de 10 aujourd'hui je vous ai
montre d'ailleurs que des plages des
remet au faut sortir près de quoi lots
voilà et sinon moi j'ai beaucoup sauvés
alors un moment jeu des blues et des
aigles avec mon père on avait de sortir
des pièges de braconniers
non non ça c'est bon et ben vous dire à
plusieurs reprises ils s'en sont pris à
nous donc je suis très fier de ça à
bravo l'histoire de mode de battues et
fois avec pas nous l'a raconté dans un
instant envoyé vérité vérité pas on a
que d'histoires il fallait vraiment que
l'histoire du gecko il invente si
c'était des histoires inventées en plus
je rome